comment sont donné les codes de l'armé
nucléaire est ce qu on a du temps pour
sa vie privée quand on est président at
on le droit de pleurer qu'est ce que ça
fait de négocier avec vladimir poutine
france peut-elle encore à l'échelle du
monde ou est elle soumise à des
superpuissances des questions sur les
coulisses du quotidien d'un président de
la république on en a plein et en même
temps c'est normal c'est littéralement
la personne la plus puissante du pays
mais du coup je me suis dit tant qu'à
faire pourquoi ne pas essayer de poser
ses questions directement un ancien
président de la république j'ai tenté ma
chance et françois hollande a accepté
c'est le premier épisode de ce nouveau
format vous pouvez vous abonner pour ne
pas louper les vidéo suivante mais bon
bonjour c'est vrai merci d'avoir accepté
seulement des changes aujourd'hui avec
nous alors première question on va
revenir le 6 mai 2012 c'est à ce moment
là que face à nicolas sarkozy vous êtes
élu président de la république française
qu'est ce qui se passe et comment ça se
passe quand on réalise qu'on est le
prochain président à un public d'abord
ne découvre pas que l'on est le prochain
président de la république on s'y est
préparé le dimanche du deuxième tour il
y a les sondages qui d'ailleurs ne sont
pas encore le vote des français mais il
est clair que j'étais à ce moment là le
favori de l'élection j'apprends que je
suis président de la république par la
succession des instituts de sondage qui
au téléphone informe que le résultat va
être sur d'autres de 52 48 alors comment
être sûr
d'être le président certes tu reçois un
coup de téléphone de nicolas sarkozy qui
accepte sa défaite et qui
encourage son successeur mais c'était
pas non plus une officialisation de la
victoire alors qu'est ce que je fais je
fais comme tous les français je
m'installe sur un fauteuil ou sur un
canapé et j'adore le journal de 20h son
visage apparaît à 20 heures je me dis
bon bah maintenant je suis président de
la république pourquoi
je prends cette précaution non pas parce
que le cac pourrait changer entre 19h et
20h basque à 20h tous les français
savent qu'ils aient leur président et
c'est le moment qui fait que je suis
président la joie dure peu de temps je
voulais dit je m'étais préparé à cette
élection est tout de suite vient à la
fois la responsabilité parce que dès les
premières minutes je reçois des coups de
téléphone de du monde entier de barack
obama dans quel à merkel d'autres il ya
du monde a investi notamment moi j'avais
15 ans mais je me souviens de ces images
impressionnantes à la place de la
bastille plein de monde et et avant la
place de la bastille avait si je puis
dire leur place de la cathédrale à tulle
ferret et il ya des milliers de
personnes qui sont là j'ai pas bien sûr
préparé de discours
souvent il est dit les candidats
préparent deux discours un discours de
défaite et un discours de victoire moi
je me suis pas livré cet exercice
comment imaginer sa défaite ou comment
être sûr de sa victoire donc j'ai
attendu qu'il y ait cette annonce et de
vote des français et donc j'ai à
m'exprimer et d'abord devant cette foule
joyeuse et ensuite j'avais à prendre
rapidement un avion pour aller place de
la bastille et je suis arrivé très tard
d'ailleurs vous avez dit notamment on ne
devient pas président dès qu'on entre à
l'elysée on ne devient pas ancien
président des condenseurs presque on
devient pas président dès qu'on entre à
l'elysée oui il faut habiter la fonction
il faut aussi comprendre le rite qui va
être celui d'un président il faut
appréhender non pas les problèmes mais
déjà les premières réponses qu'il faut
apporter les réunions qui vont arriver
et puis à une part d'inconnu comment se
passe un conseil européen je n'y avais
jamais siégé comment se passe
g8 g20 et puis rencontrer les dirigeants
qui je connaissais par la télévision et
que je n'avais jamais eu l'occasion de
voir en face à face il faut pas non plus
que ce temps là d'initiation si je puis
dire soit trop long il faut assumer
pleinement la fonction tout en
apprenant son rôle de président et dans
cette arrivée au pouvoir
question qui revint beaucoup qui est
plein aussi de de fantasmes ou
d'interrogation a minima c'est que sont
très concrètes c'est la question de
l'armé nucléaire on lit ici et là que
lorsque vous arrivez au pouvoir et bien
vous transmet des fameux codes qui
permettent d'activer d'utiliser l'armé
nucléaire certains évoquent aussi une
transmission son appel aux pc jupiter
que donc un poste de commandement des
dizaines de mètres sous l'elysée comment
ça se passe cette question de l'armé
nucléaire c'est question qui revient
souvent quand on accède à cette fonction
de président république comment est-ce
qu'on accède aussi à cette
responsabilité oui il y a des vies tout
est mystère qui se transmettent de
génération en génération depuis le début
de la vème république puisque le chef de
l'état et
l'autorité qui peut déclencher le feu
nucléaire chacun imagine que le
président sortant sort de sa poche un
code secret qui l'aurait gardé
précieusement sur lui et le le donne à
son successeur non ça n'est pas possible
et heureusement que ce n'est pas
possible il y a effectivement une
procédure et heureusement que le chef de
l'état tout seul ne peut pas déclenché
le feu atomique et donc avec le
président
sortant et le président entrant qui lie
à un examen des grands dangers qui
menacent mais en aucune façon
une transmission en échange d'une
mallette d'un code ou je ne sais quel
est le moyen de déclencher le feu
nucléaire en revanche vous avez raison
quelques heures après le président
nouvellement élu va dans le coeur si
l'on peut dire qui est un endroit
sécurisé où il lui ai expliqué la façon
avec laquelle il pourrait dans une
situation bien sûr exceptionnel si notre
territoire était envahi ou si nous
étions nous mêmes frappés déclenché
larmes du coeur donc je veux rassurer
des jeunes générations il n'y a pas de
risque d'un président comme dans des
films le docteur folamour vous bien
considérer que choisir un président
c'est pas un acte innocent s'est aperçu
qu aux etats unis quand donald trump
accéder à la présidence il ya eu des
interrogations sur sa liberté de pouvoir
engager des forces ou pouvoir même
déclenché le feu nucléaire une question
là aussi car j'aime beaucoup quand on
demande à des gens quelques essais
j'aimerais poser au président de la
république c'est la question du poids de
la france notamment à l'échelle
internationale vous avez passé cinq ans
à l'elysée a rencontré les plus grands
chefs d'état est ce que vous allez
sentiment que en tant que président la
république française on peut changer le
monde corrigé l'évolution du monde oui
la preuve lorsque j'ai organisé la la
coop 21 sur la question climatique c'est
un événement fait que je me suis
peut-être poser cette question si je
n'avais pas été président est ce que il
y aurait eu sept comme 20e sur banc est
ce qu'elles auraient eu lieu à paris
sûrement pas est ce que nous aurions
réussi l'accord qui c'est qui peut le
prétendre donc oui à un président de la
république française peut
provoquer une évolution heureuse
j'espère du monde prenons un autre
exemple une intervention militaire
extérieure peu de pays en décide mais il
se trouve que la france membre permanent
du conseil de sécurité il ya que cinq
pays qui sont membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité a une responsabilité
mondiale et dispose des moyens de
défense peut être appelé par un pays
pour
justement lutter contre l'intéressé ce
qui s'est fait donc quand j'ai fait
intervenir les forces françaises au mali
ou plus tard aussi encore miracle c'est
vrai que ça a des conséquences et il est
bien certain nombre de sujets y compris
lors de votre quinquennat qui pour
certains ont montrée peut-être une
certaine faiblesse de la france par
rapport à des acteurs internationaux
l'un de ces exemples c'est les
révélations qu'il ya eu sur les systèmes
de surveillance mise en place par les
états unis notamment on a eu à wikileaks
qui a révélé en 2015 qu'il y avait un
système d' écoute avec l'ambassade
américaine en france elle était
confirmée ensuite par une note de
l'année s'est révélée par par libération
et mediapart face à ce sujet face à ces
révélations la réaction française avait
été jugé assez molle et certains avaient
douté du coût de la capacité de la
france à résister puisque les états unis
seraient
beaucoup plus puissant avec la france et
donc il faudrait s'incliner face à ces
pratiques c'est que notre cyber sécurité
n'était pas à mon sens suffisamment
intense technologiquement élevé pour
nous prémunir contre ce type de
surveillance nous avons fait pas osé
terrier que c'était des comportements
comme curieux d'espionner ses propres
aux alliés alors que ces mêmes peu
suffisant de dire curieux est-ce que
c'est pas grave intolérable même mais ne
croyez pas non plus que la france reste
inerte sur ces questions là que nous
avons aussi des services qui essayent de
justement de nous protéger quelques fois
de regarder ce que font d'autres mais
pas nos alliés c'est la grande
différence avec les états unis et est-ce
que lors de votre quinquennat justement
vous avez senti par moments que la
france n'était pas assez forte a minima
seul pour faire face à les sujets
internationaux où elle se sentait être
une fois une fois j'ai eu le sentiment
que nous aurions pu agir seul et que
nous ne pouvions pas parce qu'il y avait
un environnement qui n'était pas le
meilleur je vais prendre cet exemple là
lorsque bachar el-assad en syrie a
infligé donc à sa propre population des
souffrances terribles avec l'utilisation
des armes chimiques j'étais favorable à
ce que avec les états unis et le royaume
uni nous puissions punir le régime de
bachar el-assad en frappant sa vente
d'installations s'il fallait aller au
delà du droit international ce qui est
toujours un problème pour la france
barack obama a tardé à donner sa réponse
et a renvoyé à plus tard résultat ce que
je pensais être une réponse nécessaire
une frappe indispensable mais tout ça
n'a pas eu lieu et ça a eu des
conséquences graves donc voilà quelques
fois la france seule ne peut pas agir
autant qu'il le faudrait on n'a pas été
écartée mais c'est la façon dont ma
préféré négocier directement avec
poutine pour évacuer les armes chimiques
de syrie d'ailleurs elles ne l'ont pas
toutes été plutôt que de s'associer à ce
qui avait été un moment convenu entre
lui et moi bon voilà donc on est obligé
de tenir compte des rapports de force
dans l'un de vos livres justement vous
raconter un sommet avec vladimir poutine
de discussions assez facile houleuse et
le bon mot mais vous décrivez notamment
un quelqu'un de chaleureux enveloppant
attentionné et tout à coup complètement
glaçant comment est ce qu'on fait pour
négocier face à une personnalité comme à
vladmir poutine
est-ce que c'est pas ici aussi que une
coopération européenne est une forme
selon vous de solutions parce que en
gala merkel dit a dit notamment je
préfère que tu sois là il faut être
plusieurs pour affronter la pression de
la demi-heure faute in vladimir poutine
est
un chef d'état qui est là depuis
longtemps et qui veut y rester aussi
longtemps
autant qu'il sera possible la tête de
son pays il le manie à la fois
forme de courtoisie n'avaient pas dire
d'élégance mais de brutalité ta mélange
donc de douceur apparente de d'amitié
prodigués et un moment de dureté dans la
négociation donc
la preuve fois que j'ai rencontré
l'avenir vous dites j'ai eu tout de
suite cette impression qu'il était
capable de d'aller assez loin dans la
menace et le maniement de la force bon
voilà il faut faut savoir ça et à partir
de là dans les négociations je pense que
merkel avait besoin que sur l'ukraine
notamment ou sur d'autres sujets elle ne
se retrouve pas seul et la france
n'avait pas intérêt à la laisser seule
ou à nous mettre seul face à vladimir
poutine dont qu'il était légitime que
les deux principaux pays bien ce se
mettent ensemble pour obtenir de
belleval hybrides et des retraits ou des
cessez-le-feu et c'était nécessaire mais
la diplomatie pour que chacun comprenne
bien c'est pas simplement une habileté
ses interventions on négocie bien si on
va trouver le bon argument c'est d'abord
un rapport de force s'il ya pas le
rapport de force vous pouvez avoir le
meilleur ambassadeur le meilleur
ministre affaires étrangères le meilleur
président eh bien il ne tiendra pas
longtemps vadimir poutine il utilise
toujours le rapport de force et il
s'arrête quand ils pensent qu'il y à un
risque sérieux pour ses propres intérêts
votre quinquennat était marqué par
une série d'attentats et lorsque vous
rentrez dans la cour d'honneur des
invalides à lors de la cérémonie
d'hommage aux victimes du 13 novembre on
voit évidemment très marqué submergée
d'une certaine façon par l'émotion quand
on est président de la république
finalement est ce qu'on a le droit est
ce qu'on peut s'autoriser à pleurer ou
est-ce qu'on doit se retenir je ne
voulais pas donner l'impression au
moment où nous étions frappés que moi
même je pouvais
marquer une faiblesse quelconque mais je
ne pouvais pas non plus montré une
insensibilité alors que des victimes et
le procès se déroule en ce moment sont
nombreuses et qu'elles sont
douloureusement atteinte et donc quand
il y a eu cette cérémonie je voulais
marquer bien sûr de la gravité
mais il ya un moment quand les chansons
ont été entonnés par les trois
chanteuses qui était là et bien là
le froid qui nous saisissent et je n'ai
pas pu l'émotion qui était en moi est ce
que quand on est président on a peur et
si c'est le cas dans quelles
circonstances peur non je ne crois pas
d'abord si c'est une peur physique les
services de sécurité sont là et il vous
protège que je suis allé sur les lieux
des attentats parce que je considérais
que c'était mon devoir et je n'ai pas
peur je savais qu'il pouvait y avoir un
risque peur de me retrouver dans une
négociation intervenants ou jamais je
pense et quelquefois que salée elle est
éprouvant que ça dure les critiques
les quolibets et les moqueries les
réseaux sociaux qui joue qui caquettent
fois vous surprennent par parleurs leur
message de de contestation qui va même
au delà avec parfois touche à la haine
on peut être un peu bouleversé vous
savez comment c'est possible de dire
autant de mal de ce que je peux le faire
ce que je mérite bien tout ça et il ya
quand même plus de critiques que de
compliments mais c'est pas la peur cessé
ces deux questions dans ma nature est
plutôt d'être attentif aux autres plutôt
expansif et et de manier l'humour
or dans une fonction comme celle là vous
êtes obligés d'être retenu non pas aux
réserves mais en tout cas en faisait
savez que vous êtes tout le temps
observer et donc pour faire attention à
ces gestes à ces attitudes et même à ses
paroles une question maintenant ce sera
sera l'avant dernière je pense y aller
le rythme de vie d'un président de la
république et comment est ce qu'on fait
notamment pour concilier vie privée et
vie présidentiel est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui est possible et ce
qu'on a du temps pour soi aujourd'hui
c'est à tour du chaque jour est une
prise de parole chaque jour parce que
même s'il ne l'a pas souhaité d'une
façon sa parole sera enregistré vous
pouvez filmer serait échangée inconnu et
donc il ya aucune conversation même qui
restent
secrètes ou limitées et en plus il ya
une voracité des sources d'informations
aussi bien des chaînes en continu que
dès que des réseaux c'est très difficile
c'est très difficile parce que il y a
beaucoup de déplacements beaucoup de
voyages il ya des soirées qui sont
occupées par des réunions il y a des
matins qui sont très tôt et des nuits
très courtes c'est ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre un président david plus chez
lui moi même j'ai essayé de garder mon
appartement pendant deux ou trois ans et
c'est devenu impossible parce qu'il faut
sécuriser quartier pour les aînés et les
autres locataires ou occupants de
l'immeuble se plaignent au bout d'un
certain moment de la sécurité des
agitations donc un moment vous allez à
l'elysée c'est tellement plus simple
hélas hélas votre vie se se referme sur
elle-même et toute sortie devient
difficile allez marcher dans la rue
c'est ça paraît tout simple fièrement
qu'elle quel plus beau mode de
distraction que d'aller marcher un
moment dans un pack ou même faire les
magasins allez sur un marché comprendre
ce que vivent les gens ne devient
finalement ou un artifice de
communication ou lourdeur il ya des
premiers ministres dans des pays
d'europe du nord qui continue à aller
faire leur marché faire leurs courses
pays avec leur carte bleue etc et quand
ils ne le font pas ces chefs de
gouvernement ils sont
durement jugée en france c'est très
difficile à la fois pour des raisons de
sécurité pour les autres statues du roi
dont le président pas se commettre à
faire des actes de la vie quotidienne et
pourquoi pas est-ce qu'on se sent
coupable quand on s'accorde ces moments
de pause en tant que président de
république on sent pas coupable jusqu'au
moment où olli sur les réseaux sociaux
que il était inadmissible d'aller au
cinéma ou de prendre trois jours de
vacances je vais prendre un exemple j'ai
été élu deux ans en mai 2012 et je suis
parti quelques jours en congés en août
2012 en plus j'avais pris de rangement
et dansons pour bien montrer que c'était
aussi un lieu de travail eh bien j'ai
été très très critique écrit comment
plupart qui ont aujourd'hui on est plus
indulgent je crois les gardes emmanuel
macron je prends un autre exemple parce
que c'était vrai même avant d'être
président quand on va faire un
déplacement aux antilles des images qui
reviennent on dit pas comment il était
en vacances aux antilles non le
président il doit aller partout et
jamais pensé que s'il va quelque part
c'est pour son propre plaisir on a parlé
de votre arrivée au pouvoir on a parlé
de un peu des coulisses de cette vie à
l'elysée la question logiquement que
vous vous posez c'est la question de la
presse d'abord que dit-on peut-être au
nouveau président donc ici en france
emmanuel macron lors de cette passation
de pouvoir quand on est président on
doit comprendre qu'on ne le sera pas
toujours qu'est ce qu'on dit à son
successeur
on lui dit que d'abord il ya des
problèmes à régler qu'on lui transmet
mais qu'on a des solutions pour emmanuel
macron il avait été au gouvernement donc
il savait exactement peut-être mieux que
d'autres quelle était la situation ils
devraient se rappeler aussi de ce que
nous avions réussi il faut se préparer à
cet instant extrêmement brutal où vous
êtes président à 11 heures et à 11h02
vous êtes rue du faubourg saint-honoré
et vous n'êtes pas complètement un
citoyen comme les autres vous êtes aux
yeux de beaucoup encore un président
mais vous n'êtes plus le président donc
il faut se dire comment je vais être
utile comment je peux être utile
ou
je reste finalement dans ma vie
personnelle et je rends utile à ma
famille mes proches mes amis où j'essaie
d'être encore utile tout en étant plus
présidence et où la voie que j'ai
choisie
j'avais créé une fondation et des dénés
les initiatives et les innovations les
associations qui me paraissaient les
plus
ouverte au monde et à ses problèmes bon
ben voilà il faut que chaque ancien
président sache comment il peut être
utile quand il n'est plus président
merci beaucoup merci pour ce moment ça
les change ça me semblait intéressant
d'avoir comme ça ce moment d'échangé
avec vous monsieur le président sur
cette fonction encore une fois qui
fascine qui interroge aussi et de se
plonger comme ça le temps d'un échange
assez long sur les coulisses de tout ça
ça me semble assez assez intéressant il
faut écarter les mythes les fantasmes
les illusions pour peut-être mieux
prendre en compte la réalité même de la
fonction encore merci de décrypter
fonction présidentielle
qui fut un beau plus transparent que
vous l'imaginiez merci à vous merci
encore et merci à vous du coup n'hésitez
pas évidemment à vous abonner je ne sais
pas encore le cas pour ne pas louper les
vidéos suivantes on est quand même sur
youtube il faut il faut le dire la
puissance 10 du coût à très vite pour
d'autres vidéos encore merci à monsieur
le président à bientôt merci